[Music]
Stephen twitch boss's wife Allison
holker is dealing with the legal
aftermath of his death by Suicide
according to Court docs obtained by E.T
twitch died without a will forcing
Allison to file a California spousal
property petition in La this is a
routine procedure where the surviving
spouse has to file a petition to prove
that they are the spouse of the person
who died further Court filing Allison
requested twitch's half of Stephen boss
Productions and his Goldman Sachs
investment account as well as royalties
from a number of companies where twitch
earned income according to the docs
Allison is asking for a determination of
property passing to the surviving spouse
as well as confirmation of property
belonging to the surviving spouse
twitch and Allison tied the knot in
2013. I have the sweetest husband in the
entire world in the weeks following
twitch's suicide in December the Dancing
with the Stars Alum shared an emotional
tribute on Instagram writing to my
husband best friend babe chichalker
Superman and father of my children I
love you forever and always the way we
approach life is we kind of look at life
as being our playground you know so we
like to try new things Allison and
twitch have two children together
six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya twitch is
also dad to holker's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean Allison
added that they will forever remember
twitch as a true Beacon of light before
thanking him for the memories and
Beautiful Life they share together I
feel like we connect a lot through dance
so it's just sometimes fun like to have
a partner in life that I can also dance
with you know it just makes every single
day so fun
Allison later shared this clip dancing
around the house with twitch alongside
the caption our love language
[Music]
and a source previously told E.T how she
is keeping twitch's memory alive for
their children quote Allison is making
sure that all the kids know how much
their daddy loves them that he is still
with them and his spirit is still
flourishing that this has nothing to do
with them and that they can do things to
help keep his Spirit Alive
[Music]